I
brilliant nicely done or welcome to the
Friday review of games IV Andy Lewis I'm
Dan Galpin and it is Friday April
twentieth 2012 and it's very exciting to
be here we've got a great selection of
games but as always we're starting off
with our selection of grew so with this
always as big Pete big Pete once again
who is whose return to us purchase and
so over over here we were showing off
the amazing I don't know what do we
probably defer do it it is peg droid we
showed off k droid and cake droid was
pouring actually Paul's own home brew
which is very exciting which was
delicious and but for us the actual beer
of the week for this April twentieth is
humbled brown hemp ale so these are and
we've got a great selection of games as
I mentioned earlier present look at with
us later on we're going to bring in our
senior senior India correspondent to
help work on one of the games so this is
this is very exciting to us it's the
first time you had a guest on the
program here on the Friday review at
least a guest a Googler so I'm cheers
cheers to you my friend all right so
let's start off with a game that just
rings a lot of bells for me it brings
back some happy and unhappy memories 2xl
MX off road which is the spitting image
of the first game that I ever did for
the ps2 which I was Jeremy McGrath
Supercross it sucks for for many reasons
but the Cape we're gonna skip this right
here get turn off the sound
right we're looking good all right so so
it's a first off I mean it's beautiful
game beautiful experience to begin with
a really nice animation this screen was
actually a little confusing to me but uh
yeah looks like it worked out I think
partially because i had a tablet and i'm
looking at a phone like it is my
simulating my phone on my tablet I was
trying to figure out what was going on
but now I understand right now I want to
mention while this is loading that this
isn't the first loading screen we've
seen it does actually download a
tremendous amount of resources to begin
with I and they don't download in the
background so Dan actually wrote this
amazing library for background downloads
that you should really check out so to
let you do all that resource loading
without having to keep the the title
screen your game up all the time yes I
like to you know i'm downloading a game
i have other things i'd like to do and
check my mail or talk to somebody online
and that's a that's not possible with
this game yeah anyway basically what it
does is it runs a kind of a download
manager like service in the background
and it puts up a notification in the
notification area that a lot of people
see the progress and it also does some
feedback to your applications so that
your application can report progress and
it tries to calculate approximate
download time and a few other things it
was done as part of the apk expansion
file project and it's mostly designed
for downloading that but it's actually
very easy to appropriate it to download
whatever you would like and the audio is
a bit hot good to know we'll keep it a
little quiet alright well I don't know
why it's our problem we just have loud
voices we do have thoughtful Trevor back
there on the mixture going to take care
of that hot audio for you pal I think
how about now all right okay let's
ignore what Trevor and right are talking
about by the way this show and the
engineer is Trevor John's producer is
the incomparable reto Meier exact father
of Android development what the book
yes okay that's better okay let's take a
look at this gameplay I think it's
really impressive I mean it's uh I love
the arcade feel of this game yeah i mean
i mean honestly i'm usually one who
wants my my my simulations to play like
tube8 just wicked fun and this game is
fun how whether you're crashing into
trees or doing jumps I kind of wanted to
be able to prep for jumps and maybe I
just never quite figured out the
controls well enough but it's still just
kind of stupid fun the framerate is
spectacular you really can't see that
over the Hangout but this game runs
buttery smooth on on our transformer
Prime's which is always great to see you
know I'd like to have a little more
texel density in it but you know
honestly it's it's really nice it's
that's the only the only complaint that
I have is the texel density on the track
is really blurry like detailed text here
or something like that even in a vacuum
I would make that man plan but
especially since the texel density on
the on the biker is so bright yeah but
yeah the the smoothness just can't be
beat it's really amazing the control is
actually controllable which surprises me
i ate accelerometer games that just i
suck at them but yeah no I'm not I I
totally get with you and a teller ometer
is really really precise really
responsive I was really pleased so so
something things to note about this game
this game has all of the classic
problems that you see in android titles
it plays music on the lock screen it
does not handle the back button
correctly so all those things that have
to be looked at before the editorial
board here would even consider looking
at it and as a feature on the other hand
you know the game is so beautiful and so
well done I can't imagine why they
wouldn't so you know those those are
just things to consider even with games
that are really really polished like
this not having those things really
makes it an on Android experience and
it's kind of it's kind of sad because I
would love to see this up there so with
a few minor changes I think it's ready
absolutely I'd love to see the
background downloads I'd love to see I'd
love to see the the back key and
yeah and get rid of those uh menu
buttons of shame yes the many buttons of
shame now that that brings up an
interesting point we had a comment
earlier on our Google+ page asking about
the buttons of shame and saying is it
possible to turn them off for just turn
him on for just one activity instead of
keeping them on for the entire
application mm-hmm and the answer with
that is no as far as far as I I didn't
know of a way to do it either I know the
point was i he was sort of in the same
boat that the question was in the same
boat as the robo sockets guys where they
had a piece of middleware that needs a
menu button yeah our general response is
if you're writing metal where you know
don't make it so your guys can't get
featured you know I'll take your
middleware especially if it's something
that's trying to monetize I mean it's
just you know it's just like so you know
my my my general feeling is we should
make sure that anyone who's doing
middleware Android action allows that
would make good android you know quality
stuff and you know so we actually talked
to the featuring team about this um and
the response was you know yeah we will
ding you for using middleware that
violates our our design guidelines
because otherwise you know how would how
would it ever change yeah well maybe
like you'd be like oh well you're using
that middleware so you don't quite have
to look like everything else and that's
just not that's not fair i mean oh it
will be cool dang the whole point of
middleware hopefully is that it makes
your life easier it doesn't make it
harder oh you know that's that's that's
that's always the goal but you know
we're more than happy to engage with
these guys we keep up regular relations
with a lot of middleware companies um if
your middle where is causing your game
problems so you're not getting featured
on android market I'm sorry google play
take a drink exactly every time every
time you say android market you have to
take a drink but i think it should be
this key yeah would be nice silly
android market drinking game protected
to you on the game
review session on Fridays all right in
any case oh so we are I we are talking
to the middle where we actually spent
several hours on the phone with middle
work in Beijing last week there they're
going to go ahead and fix their stuff a
lot of times the middleware actually is
has a fix in the works they just haven't
updated so they definitely need to make
sure that the update and that you keep
current with what every middleware is a
lot of times they will fix problems so
I'll say one more thing about 2xl MX
off-road just just just just a con my
final point let's say it'll take a take
one more look at the screen here of V
and then go back to go back to the if
you go back to look at their icon
actually this is kind of an interesting
one the out there there launcher icon
okay this is something that you see a
lot and their launcher icon has what I
when I call the round rectangle of shame
and and for summary if you go and look
at all the stock icons on Android none
of them with the exception of Google
Plus which really shouldn't be that way
it's actually around rectangle to all of
them are uniquely shaped icons and here
you have this really really cool looking
you know bicycle on the in the icon so I
think that's what it is although its
heart be to see from here um well I
think they could like a motorcy it's a
motorcycle motorcycle and MX bike and um
and it's got this weird rectangle around
it and it'd be so much cooler if it
didn't like like it should just be like
this this this cool biker against
whatever background you have you looking
if you compare it to the only icon here
actually of all of these that's really
really perfect for android is actually
the last one here that's that's what an
Android I attend should look like it
should not be around a rectangle unless
there's a really good reason for it
being rounded rectangle yeah I mean
there's it and you mentioned the G+ I
fine and that that is actually the you
know that's see I can these on the web
etc it's you know but look at look at
Shane reaction look at neon Neil Raja uh
both
those just have an icon that they placed
a rounded rectangle background behind ya
before no I think we know what the
reason is yes but hey man don't rub it
in our faces dude so yeah I thought was
just one more car I want to mix instance
we were there and we were being nitpicky
like this game is so awesome and make it
feel just more like an Android
experience by giving it an icon that
actually kind of works with our icon
guidelines oh yeah all that stone make
it made some marketing people happy you
know that's and that's well and that's
really the important thing right because
I think we've talked about making us
happy you know it doesn't really help
that much making marking people happy
you know that's what that's what that's
what you keep using the top list so you
know yeah so yeah because it goes it
goes from editorial which is all gamers
who to QA which is testers from the game
industry that know how to break things
like nobody's business and then it goes
from merchandising and all they look at
is how pretty is your graphic yeah well
what is your icons exactly all all this
stuff so it's funny cuz you can happen
but you can have the best game in the
world but if your feature graphic is
terrible and they and the team decides
to feature it then you end up with like
really low placement or you know some
some like slot way down in the back in
the basement of market or no one sees
its ok Google Play so there we are I
think I clearly had too much of that
beforehand I do really like about the
Paul Paul's breweries excellent that's a
little bad yeah I'm really it's really
interesting we won a little bit more
mall personally but mm this is nice
though it is healthier yeah yeah didn't
really taste the hump but I don't know
what I don't know what I haven't really
like so but no but uh it's gas gets just
a little bit of hop in it so know what I
expected it to taste like but not that
so we do have a habit had a developer
who's joining us online as well so we'll
have to get to I don't know what yeah
yeah well actually that's the game
that's up right now we're about to like
a chain reaction shot petrol joining us
online hey bro Pedro where you at where
you coming from now that I think you did
a land of mute hold on we may be able to
fix this
they worked fine in the last session I
know we had we thought night fed
resonated no maybe not can you hear him
Trevor no do you see like little volume
bars on the bottom try talking again
then now i know i need you're your
microphone screwed yeah working man I
was so I always I was so hoping uh bauer
i can pull up chat because we get I only
if only if only we knew some like common
styling yeah yeah all right okay Petra
if yo put yeah you can you can go in
like the chat window maybe and and you
can respond that way yeah a group chat
window seeking if you can and you can
type stuff to us and you can wait look
we're going we're going on oh wait whoa
whoa we heard you hey all right me yeah
okay I had to and I understand well well
welcome welcome so you're gaming last
let me just let me just say that when in
which witch is which is which is really
cool and Indian has more to say I know I
know this this game is hilarious so I
where were you coming from Portugal
portal portal in Portugal oh wow okay oh
my favorite Portuguese city yeah we
recently let we certainly like up pour
tous here so that yeah that's great okay
so yeah so you know the the gameplay is
a little bit reminiscent of defender or
you know just one of these yeah Wow no I
can i restart this level cuz yeah you're
about to get your about tickets yeah oh
man well and actually this is one of the
day yeah but that's not that I love that
yeah I so one of things I really really
loved about this game was first of all
your your intro mm-hmm oh oh yeah it
looks let's test back I just a second
although check out my score I know 420
it works well for today you know I think
that's worth another drink of the of the
humble crown right there um
so this thing walks the line all right
if you take a look at what the message
box we have on the screen right now
Trevor would you mind bringing that up
okay so it says ray chain reaction and
get eight hundred coins bonus um if that
said ray chain reaction five stars and
get an eight hundred gender bonus I you
your account would be banned okay um
this is just a blocking the line it's a
little on the shady side that's okay
yeah exactly I thought a lot about
including that that dialogue but i
thought well since I'm actually asking
for the gamer to quit my game to go
right then I might might as well give
him a reason to come back yeah I was I
wasn't really sure about about doing it
yeah yeah it's one of the it's
definitely borderline and it's not you
know it's not it's not clear if the long
term worded that that's something to be
weaving it allow but definitely you know
it's least you're not saying you know
give us five stars which is actually
worse so right you're saying you're
saying I believe my game is awesome dude
and give it five stars anyways and I'm
going to give you a hundred coins just
to that okay so let's go to the game
this is a really fun game and you know I
mean it's mostly about moving your guy
and shooting the right zombie and then
getting getting your power-ups so you
can do better in the future I'm assuming
that in the future my aim one suck as
bad as it does right now um so the only
thing if it's bent on a tumble plan yeah
in the future oh man these had lice a
level of fast zombies um okay so here's
the thing I think that moving my guy is
a big part of the game play here I think
that's that's part of the expertise like
I can actually shoot from anywhere I
don't actually understand what that is
but oh yeah alright well let me try and
explain this well while I'm not trying
to play so I can shoot from anywhere
which i think is really cool but you
we get a good beat on the zombie if
you're shooting from an advantageous
point on the board right so you want to
move your guy up and down so that he can
get a good shot the UI for moving the
guy up and down is really tough because
you actually have to to touch on one
side or the other of the guy so my main
suggestions just make this game 10 times
more enjoyable for for old losers like
me is making a slider working in a
certain way exactly like I really want
to just just move my thumb up and down
and have the guy follow me yeah I
realized that that the movement scheme
might be a problem while I was making
the the trailer for the game that was
the first time I actually played the
game on a tablet and yeah yeah don't you
kill the edges I out it right to the
thumb book slightly good boy yeah had
actually considered that courts were
playing it on our tablets because I
we're like you know you leave here with
our well and that is something that you
know to be aware of is that you know
obviously and just just as an aside you
know when when the Android team decides
to feature an app on Google Play I they
do it for a number of reasons but
remember the ultimate goal is to benefit
the Android team is to benefit the the
ecosystem as a whole and one of the
things we really want to make sure I
visit people who spend money on Android
tablets get a really good experience so
right so the game review board that
we've talked about before a number of
volunteers play a lot of video games
most of them have some experience in the
video game industry and we actually just
issued them a galaxy tens or asus
transformer primes to test the games you
think Shane is a lucky bastard yeah so
these uh so these people are testing on
some high-end hardware we want to make
sure the game shows up as good as you
can you know we're not say no
he's saying oh you know it doesn't run
on my droid incredible so you know that
sucks or whatever but it does mean that
you need to pay some attention to how
your game looks on a tablet now
fortunately we now have a tablet
emulator they can actually run GL and
can give you a little bit more
experience with that even if you're
going on a tablet right but that's not
going to help you with this problem yeah
and actually the one thing to note about
about it is tues you can always get the
density the pixel density as well as the
screen size and that can help you
calibrate controls too that's it just
kind of it's definitely useful to see
that when you're on those bigger screen
sizes what kind of tells you have well
my ain't really does suck um but I'm not
the only one no no I I mean this is a
very different game um now I haven't
upgraded at all Oh ye'd upgrade yeah um
now what's a hammer thing can I actually
hammer my oh I see there we go yes I'm
really cool I'm seeing all this kind of
thing for you seeing that what kind of
stuff oh you're seeing some really
interesting graphical glitches yeah I
will be able to get that working you
look older did something I have this
turned on okay yeah yeah so none right
for those of you watching at home they
don't actually seem like what ya doing
so he's got the he's got the development
feature turned on where you can actually
show touches which I should probably
have turned on and it's just causing
some graphical glitch it usually doesn't
but in this case it does it's not
surprising it's not behave smells at all
so anyway yeah we like this game we
think your you know your upgrade
monetization strategy looks pretty cool
it's just if the controls are just a
little bit too difficult for us to
really get into it mmm I thought you
know I i like it i think that i think
it's always a i definitely think that on
a tablet you know i'd love to see the
controls get tweaked but um you know I
suspect on a phone it's probably great
so yeah that's that's it's definitely
definitely worthwhile
I would love to just be able to control
where his position is though with my
thumb I think that ye or have it almost
go exactly there that would become that
would be fun especially since you know
the that's it's a relatively small part
of the game in terms of in terms of the
difficulty of the game I think okay i'll
definitely add a secondary control
scheme that would be awesome i got a
tablet so for testing and then just uh
you know so you've got awesome you've
got some guns I let's see we've got ways
to York it's a raid shares a thousand
coins you can I tell my or three coins
and what about the coins that I can pay
for petrol where are those there this
should be the less there on my another
nine years do not have billing or
something here look the billing if if if
the billing service isn't bound then it
i think it doesn't show the yeah that
makes sense i wonder if my you know
sometimes my account just gets weird i
think ya might might are actually there
so might so it's definitely working on
mine so okay cool I some stuff yeah I
don't you know actually it's funny
because in the last review rato and Fred
we're going to buy something and then
they're like oh no I don't know whose
credit card that is guess I'm just gonna
say this right now games people we don't
care we got money forward let's see
buyers yeah say seventy thousand coins
oh whoa that didn't work at all wait
hold on um I have curiosity I'm seeing
this is so excited to buy something and
that was a massive failure let me try
with this one more okay let's see let's
see what happened you know should we
plug into yours because I don't why
don't why don't we plug this in here
okay up like it in mine yeah and I'm not
pretty able to buy anything that's gonna
happen you can plug it in and there well
let's see what goes on ya know oops okay
not all right so they're going to I do
if I ok not now all right so let's see
i'm gonna buy seventy thousand coins
here on on aerie are now worked so the
only thing that I kicked my cubic inch
which is yeah yeah all right so um
accepting by so you know this is just
just proving that you know we're not
super cheap
on on the Friday review wait how much
that cost five bucks idiot but you see
it actually left me here in in the
market so my suspicion is that what a
couple things happened this actually
often happens if if you call in to
billing service from something that's
not a UI thread actually you end up in
this in this state where you get stat
where you get things stacked in so
that's I'm curious are you making the
call to billing from from from a non UI
thread you think potentially i'm not i'm
not really sure i'll have to check if
you do it from a non UI thread it
doesn't know how to get back and you end
up getting stuck in market like this is
right now okay now that's so that's what
i think is happening but since i saw
that happen that's why i wanted i wanted
to do that and actually go and make a
purchase kind of show it the experiences
act like it yeah is this a um is this a
c++ gamer java game the cheapest way
well i made it in eclipse uh does that
mean it's a java game yeah well if you
write it using the Java language yes yes
i did it i mean i was thinking about the
game engine with us of the game engine
but i think the game engine is is also
in javelin hmm okay Oh using I can't
engine or something like that yes yes
exactly and engine cool okay awesome
sweet and early did you write the
building stuff yourself or is that the
engine that's doing it no no it's that's
another that's a code from from another
guy from the from the end engine forums
okay okay yeah it looks like it looks
like it might be calling in to billing
service from from the from the game
thread rather than you i pray that would
be my theory all but be curious to see
why that's going on because that that
should not be happening okay so really
there was only one major thing that bum
me out about Shane runner and that's
that once the reaction Oh Shane reaction
sorry hot we're not even get that now uh
and that's that once once that game
starts playing that sound never stops
yeah Here I am just playing my home
screen I got zombie noises in the pod
allows you to have epic epic web
browsing experience that's true that's
true but that might be took I literally
had to reboot my my tablet to get it to
shut up alright I stop the process but
yeah well I guess I could have done that
but my boy yeah maybe that's something
specific to the tablet maybe I don't
know I found out unlikely um yeah but
anyway that's something that you
definitely try to make sure try hitting
the home screen and see if you can
reproduce that well then this is pretty
common I think I know for for me when
I'm developing I'm working on my game
that i do right and and the problem is
that on mobile devices more than
anything else your game coexist in an
ecosystem with a lot of other processes
none of which behave correctly so you
need to have behave correctly with us
but you need to know chaos none of the
process is excellent you can't depend on
anyone that I agree all right what
you're done dude out fast well I'm not
we should for you I'm not double fisting
like you are and so anyway the point is
that you need to program defensively you
need to think a little bit about not
only what other process may be beyond
the system but what other activities you
user wants to engage it you know you're
going to be interrupted by phone calls
you're going to be interrupted by you
know having to lock the screen because
you know the guys bus came or whatever
it's very very different from a non
mobile application and so you do need to
be kind of defensive and think about all
the interruptions and crazy stuff that
can happen to you but by congratulations
the game is really fun and it's always
good to see and engine getting to use
out there i love i love a lot of what
they've done so you guys haven't had a
chance to play that it's a really nice
opengl accelerated sprite engine that
also includes some nice plug-ins for
physics and so definitely definitely
check that out they've done some great
work in petrol um so if
fix the audio problem just give us an
email and we'll put your game into the
editorial q okay great i defy and also
try to check check out if you can see
what's going on with it with the
purchasing and see if you can you can
keep that flow from doing what it was
doing on my device that's not really
it's really important I haven't really
understood how i can test the the
purchases because i always get this
version isn't compatible with with
purchases oh which you have to make sure
that the version that's on market it's
actually the same signed version that
you're testing so you actually have to
sign in and tested nor to make that work
and and then i would put use i would use
those tests queues initially just to
make sure the clothes are working right
rather than trying to refund yourself it
just gets really messy so you know for
one of the tests skews up and in your
inning a test version that you said that
you sign with the same signature it has
to match the signature that's on market
it doesn't have to be the same or does
it Trevor knows the answer to this for
testing at iipm mark does actually have
to be the same exact app that's
publisher to just have to match the
signature it needs to be greater than it
needs to be greater than or equal to the
version that's on market and it has to
have and it has to have the same
signature so yeah right now bug so you
don't have to have the same version but
it has to be the versions on market and
it has to match it has to have the same
signature so you do have to sign it with
whatever we will be seeing if you have
once you get into once you've actually
published it on market of course the
other way to do it is you can just um
whitelist your weight no you can't sorry
that's lvls be greater if the version is
on market has tech building enabled and
then you have to be good yeah he's the
diversions on market st billing enable
done you have to be greater than that
okay okay hopefully that will help help
you test those flows out and we see we
can figure those to get that problem out
that usually is what causes that problem
of it now but not managing this stat
correctly all right well we've got 15
minutes left in our show so thanks Pedro
for joining us you love chain reaction
hope to hear from you soon yeah and now
he's bringing our senior India
correspondent I think yes I don't let's
bring in the sea during India
correspondent and while he's coming in
could you grab me a mckellar sour
Belgian ale absolutely absolutely yeah
this is a now this is something I picked
up at the local
whole foods today as I I was on my way
to work tastic yeah Elgin wild ale now
mckellar is just a really interesting
brewery because it seems like all they
do is experimental beers so these are
the same people that did like the single
hop beer right oh yeah they did beer
lovers breakfast um which you know
apparently if you're very wealthy to
your lover because of fifteen bucks a
bottle yes well you know that's a that's
all you're having for breakfast though I
mean that's that's that's really not
that bad really useful in fifteen bucks
on breakfast really I'm special occasion
okay yeah it smells like I've been fine
I'm staying all right well and it's
brunch do that so you know if you think
of it like in those terms not that bad
it's a really good point yeah okay so um
so we need to we need to call in our
senior Indian correspond down because
our next game is Neil Raja and it's been
explained to us that that is not a Roger
named Neil you know actually apparently
that is Indian for blue yes I presumably
hindi 08 this he's a swarm so do we want
to go fetch him um actually Trevor would
you mind just grabbing him from the next
from next door awesome so so we're to be
without technical actual assistance or
with a while you should have done these
bollywood that's exactly why I was
discussing beers exactly nothing we're
hoping to but we're actually we're
actually not a radio there we are senior
India correspondent it's you know it's
just our hint system around here takes a
little longer to actually say all right
yeah right on in come on and join us
actually I'll kneel here you can sit
down and and because you're gonna get on
the city waiting so long i'm the kinda
exactly yeah exactly so welcome to an
eruv who's here visiting from the day I
wat and and it's it's great to have him
here in the office he's been doing a lot
of great work he actually writes code
which is which is which is nice and
we're gonna put new Dodger Tim screw
yeah yeah so but it but but you might
recognize him from stack overflow or
from you know other events that have
gone on and anyway it's been great hurry
is an excellent series of action movies
it's true yeah
haha so he so he's gonna we're going to
show off an eel Raja here and take it
away yeah so what I do you like a like
about this game is it's got a touch of
you added to it because it happens in
India all the time like three headed
monster studio girlfriend right why I
don't problem with the exactly see thats
exercise way that's way more exciting
than i thought had there but actually
was ok so we're going through the game
menu and there's a little story about
yeah we actually switch over to the
tablet now if you'd like to kind of show
the show our users what what honor is
looking at and so i think we got a
little story three headed monster and by
the way it does look actually kind of
that that pixelated in real life too so
in this case here no yeah yeah it's like
a total neogeo game it's awesome yeah
exactly and we'll start off with level
one and it says this is a runner game
it's not one of the ones where you run
and just immediately die i mean you have
to collect stuff in this case those gems
and and eventually you have to avoid
stuff as well and actually the game has
a really great frame rate so what you're
seeing what looks like your get about
two frames a second in the Hangout
actually the game the gay really hits 60
frames a second on on this on this town
and i wish that we didn't have to deal
with the man in the guise of youtube and
their copyright lawyers because actually
this game has a hill an infant
soundtrack killer mod player so i think
yeah i mean it sounds like a SID chip
soundtrack yeah yeah i got i was i was
convinced it was some sort of tracker
but it's it's it's it's way cool to get
a trophy music yeah yeah we all we all
really enjoy it this is this is
definitely kind of a nice retro but it's
a night oh well done retro style games
as well and the author actually mentions
how much he looks Fritz Persia and yeah
if you go back to you know all those old
yah was a true investor as I made my
hands and yes this reminds me of prince
persia it reminds me of karateka it
reminds me of all these these games in
the late 80s Early 90s that it had sort
of this similar graphical style and a
similar feel to it but they've updated
it with this you know very simple
control scheme endless
her saying that you know was is actually
a relatively recent innovation
comparatively I like it I think it's
cool i think it could use a little more
animation that's my only that's my
league yeah and in their end and this is
this is another game i think that had to
experience some of the some of some
classic you know problems so one of
things we actually ran into a few
problems was confirming what they were
now if you'd have written them down
though they did have music overlock they
did I music interlock and oh the back
key here this is a really interesting
case so so what do you do so you hit
till you hit the two the big problem
with this game is I'll tell you that the
real problem music ever lock so it
doesn't actually have music / lock what
actually happens is whenever the game is
paused it stops the music from playing
and then when you get back into the game
the game immediately start stuff without
any music so so it's kind of it's kind
of bad at multiple ways it's bad first
of all because I just I've just hit the
home screen I'm come back and I'm
immediately dead because the game is
continuing to play the second thing is
if you pause the game and unpause that
the music comes back so if the game
simply paused gameplay when it went when
it when it you would would no longer
visible it would actually solve all
these problems and it would be you and
it would almost be correct so that's one
thing the second thing is how it uses
the back key is kind of interesting to
press the back key a couple times here
to kind of show what happens here so
we're switching over to our tablet and
you see so you get up that now that to
me does not look like a dialogue so this
is one of those weird cases in which
three buttons yeah the button said two
buttons that appear and you get the back
key again you see what happens so it
just causes those those the game to go
into pause mode this is kind of I would
say unintuitive like as a general rule
we like it if the back key doesn't just
immediately quit and this is certainly
better than it just immediately quit and
user losing progress but on the other
hand it's really confusing to say how do
i click the game from here and because
it doesn't feel like a dialog you know
it definitely it definitely is a little
confusing so my feeling is it either it
should be a dialogue or in this case
this actually would be a reasonable
place for hitting the back key giving
the option opportunity to go to the menu
the best way to do this of course movie
to actually have the
then you have a continued option and not
you know and this and not actually you
know take not actually do any pausing at
all like it's in general in general we
like things behave exactly like android
on the other hand because sometimes it
can take a long time to generate and
start levels it may make sense to have a
pop-up so this is this is where we
actually have an exception to the rule
of the usual Android flow once you get
act back into the menus everything
starts working fine again so that would
be my only suggestion on this is it be
better if it was a little bit clear that
their game was paused it popped
something up if it showed up the
background great I look right out it was
really really obvious that yes my game
is paused and if it brought that same
pause game up when when we went into the
home screen it would look a lot better
be a lot better experience anything else
you want to say about this game oh I
think I think you come at the points
whether what develop imma need simple in
the game I think it's a very fun game
yeah that's cool I thought that was
definitely left up by the way so why I'm
glad I god I want I wanted to make sure
that you know that we also were being
sensitive in terms of me out this game
was offensive or something like that and
I wouldn't know so I wanted to make sure
that we brought you and you're not sure
if three-headed monster was cool yeah
exactly or like Rajas with Swedish names
that that ruins idea buscas yeah exactly
exactly okay thanks so much for joining
us guys I'm Hyderabad is that made thank
you thank you so much our senior any
partner on in alright I get back to
India yeah actually we didn't have an
offer you a beer you'd like one you're
more than welcome to have one in the
trail all right absolutely from to carry
all right the incident start off with
the next one y los well I like it under
the B rings it's open to the halls beer
all right we really just saw this
here in a you know maybe my job and say
I do your job okay whoa we all fear what
pulse beer is gone all fears gone all
right he'll be so happy you felt
excellent alright so you're gonna have
to be stuck with the sculpin alright
well it isn't india pale ale
India velo and I'm going to have an
overflow pipe here because it's kind of
overflow I can guarantee you whoa these
are both almost gone or we just out of
car are we out of I've got a feeling
there's something else going on here
well it isn't it is invading I've got a
really interesting taste we're gonna
have some disappointed coworkers ugly
yeah I know they're all plenty we're
going here and finish this off so turns
out that All Right see you later sorry
all right so our our next game is word
weasel now word weasel has been sitting
on our schedule just right under the top
40 sometime oh it's not on here at the
end and I'm sorry yeah I had to leave my
time quite sure why well we can look at
the next one I have we i have a okay we
can pull up to the one i have i have a
next one which is the one of the one
where you squish insects Oh pestilence
yeah yeah oh that's another one right i
mean these two games have literally been
sitting at like number six and seven for
the last four weeks so we don't let's
plug my name well we'll take a look at
it alright so now i actually did not do
what i would call a thorough test on
pestilence i did actually play it and
and Kane is frickin hard let me just say
this um so here's what it looks like on
a tablet now first of all you notice
that it doesn't actually size to the
full screen which makes me really sad
because it would be much cooler it's
also you friggin hard to control this
ball the Explorer this is level two can
we switch to the tablet by the way
someone's outside our window oh there is
yeah but they're not holding up like
signs or anything oh okay that pic
Damien in the mornin hahaha right oh man
I just missed it so first of all this
game is as I said it's freaking hard
partially because you have to get the
ball up to a high enough velocity to
actually squash the bug that's not just
a question of running over the bugs you
have to run over the bugs at high speed
and it's pretty fast that that high
speed is and and the maze moat is mostly
gets in your
of squashing the bugs now that's not to
say the game isn't fun it you know III
mean there and you know there are people
who are to do just like frustration and
that was my feeling is the game
immediately was just ludicrously hard
and that might possibly be because it's
not you know designed around tablets or
something but it was just like in the
game and the same is the game is really
polished like it's actually really
beautifully done mm-hmm other than I
really wanted to fill the screen and
yeah wonder why they don't fill this
brand look weird i don't know i don't
know i'm really curious as to what they
were thinking but um but yeah it's
definitely it's definitely pretty cool
and it's you know if you want a really
frustrating or if you just like really
hard games uh it's definitely uh oh okay
yes haha but any case yeah elation uh so
uh so yeah it's definitely it's
definitely challenging I think that I
would probably probably tweak it a
little bit so that it will didn't
require such enormous amount of velocity
to squash the bugs because I or me or
maybe you have levels like where you
need to have like I can I can easy level
where you can squash the bugs I pretty
much rolling the ball over it versus a
harder level where you can squash the
bug wherever actually takes some
significant velocity to do that yeah you
know and this is something that the
review committee has been coming back
this about as you know you I to get on
the on the featured list means you know
we think that your game is is going to
be interesting to a really broad
cross-section of users so we don't you
know Android and general google play in
general does not usually feature games
that are like really niche titles it
usually doesn't feature games that I you
know to just have a tiny audience or
only cover a few devices and also i am
we also don't generally feature games
that that are just way too hard unless
you have some sort of way to you know to
ratchet down the difficulty yeah and
another thing i know and it there's
there's a lot of other things too i mean
obviously if it's got some sort of
content that is
really really edgy you know it may fit
our content policy obviously that's not
something we're going to want every
little cable who opens up the store to
see so you know there are definitely
things I think squashing bugs does not
fall into that category i think in this
game really it is just that the game
immediately gets not impossible and and
so it would be great to see a little bit
more scalable difficulty on it you know
as a general rule but i think that the
game is fun the game design is very very
good um and I'd love to see I'd love to
see a little bit of ramp on it so is
that is that enough to say about this or
I think we're good okay it's a fun game
I think it we add if we had multiple
difficulty levels i think we'd we
totally want it even high and also
taking taking more of the screen that's
truly because the team might just
rejected for that reason possible okay
so the next next game is word weasel I
would i love the tip floss twice a day
by the way oh yeah yeah avoid parking
tickets by leaving your wipers or does
that work i'm totally curious about that
I really good yeah Wow huh yeah I I've
learned I've learned something on this
game already hmm okay turning points out
this looks a lot more like a badger than
a weasel or possibly even a skunk it
looks like a honey badger to me actually
but I'll tell you what what is
definitely weaselly about this as their
music you can hear it at home but this
is the most bombastic orchestral
minor-key version of pop goes the weasel
that we have ever no external this it is
we will copyrighted why don't know but I
think I think we're allowed to play a
think we're actually allowed to sing at
least 24 hours yeah thing like that okay
we're good yeah all right so this is
kind of cool because it's a it's a
social game I'm not sure actually who
I'm playing with but whatever it's
utterly social well yeah yeah join game
in progress and and then it's sort of a
what boggle is at the name of the game
so you know I can I can just make words
with this this isn't really Bible this
is something else but it's cool
I like it yeah well maybe it is but I
don't know Scotty work it's I've meet
bottles for right for I think so Rygel
is a trademark of parker brothers in
quicker yeah nor hasbro maybe I don't
know something look man I got a new next
I have a letter ace yeah it's good mmm
oh you can do he know half they don't
have to be in order oh that makes things
a lot easier yeah jot can you the only
word only a letter can leave here at
once right exactly mm-hmm right so as I
go through this i'm getting all these I
this is not a very good score that yeah
it's the pressure of the camera nice
though digit is good yeah okay all right
so yeah my my score is 32 best score was
80 13 players playing Frank seven ok
interesting interesting ok i like it i
mean this is this is this is a fun game
yeah and look at all these other games
that other words we could have done try
it I didn't know you know what I was a
word yeah so apparently God Joe is a
word apparently we are all over the map
in terms of language here it is look we
got Joe that's a Chinese word wait uh
idea I don't know what that is a GU t I
am totally confused as to whether this
game is now ah so that's our that's
maybe our issue with this game is that
we don't know what language it's using
it if it if it permits all languages
then wow I think no I would feel about
that iona I think I'm gonna get beat by
some polyglot yeah that definitely dost
it definitely does give an advantage
going out to language today that's the
idea or maybe we're supposed to learn
lots of languages or maybe a lot of
these are nonsense words I can't really
tell I don't think that it should allow
racial slurs either a good point yeah
mmm slightly wet so I think that's
actually all work under review for today
I think so yeah so what do we want to
say about word weasel well it's not the
very best tablet experience we've ever
seen there's not bad a little
disappointing that it requires a plants
or portrait mode on tablets that's
that's always a little bit awkward it'd
be nice to just adjust to whichever mode
the users more comfortable in but the
idea that you're playing against other
people and that you're you know have to
think fast in a certain amount of time
that's kind of cool yeah absolutely and
I think I think it's fun i think i think
actually these kinds of sort of casual
multiplayer titles are pretty cool I you
know there's a one of the one of the
ones i recently played was defender 2
and has a very similar thing where
you're playing against the ghost of
someone else at the same time and it's
kind of a nice way to add kind of a sort
of random challenge into the game
without half but I like actually I can't
even tell you how many how many games of
Project Gotham Racing 2 up lady gets oh
so he goes yeah yeah I think it was the
first one that we did on xbox with
ghosts and that was this yeah it was so
crazy because you'd see these things
where you had no idea how to do the
track and then follow somebody to you
still wouldn't have your idea but they
just do that yeah we're driving the same
car and then it's managed okay so
clearly I just sucked butt but yeah
that's like it's a really good point i
mean i think what we've discovered over
the last 10 years is that people love to
play each other but the asynchronous
mode I you know where you're challenging
other people is is a lot more
interesting sometimes yeah it's actually
it's actually it's a great way of adding
my social dynamic without actually
adding all of the super challenge
especially in mobile where you've got
really been latency problems of actually
actually directly challenging someone
yeah that's often very difficult unless
you're on a local network but here you
can you can challenge someone even in a
game that is if it's very twitchy and
have it still be a really good job I
think what we're saying is what we'd
love to see him word weasel is the
ability to add your friends from a
social network let's say Google+ not a
go on I think that's that's what comes
to mind anyway that's the only social
network find out
on social network I you know to be able
to add friends and maybe play against
some asynchronous let's say okay you
know I got ten words out of this one you
got 20 words out of yeah and actually
even even what would be really awesome
if you like let you know how many words
and what their score was and like and
like a Munich is there clearly much
smarter line so um so yeah that would be
fun does that ever happen to you yes hmm
yeah so sometimes sometimes you know in
embarrassing situations like hey you're
only five you should know more words
than I do but yeah but it's possible I
apologize on behalf of my children it's
possible they that I that I'd clearly
been having too much humble brown who
knows see what we do at the end of the
show is we measure how much beer is in
each person's bottle and that's who
talked the most yeah so you're saying
that I always lose it depends on how you
define winning okay well I think that's
our show for today these really suck
less today well we did have that one
technical issue we did that's true but
still don't know what happened with with
Ken right so the real question is did we
suck less than the apps guys because
they got over a hundred simultaneous
viewers today we get most of our
viewership crumbs from the YouTube
videos but you know you guys are join us
online I live we love you we count you
and we're in a constant race with the
apps guys to see who can get more so
tell your friends yeah I know I and
definite how do we do on the moderator
boats we actually did not look and so
moderator only keeps a running total but
we broke a 2100 this week I right or
both or for users okay okay no that's
that's great yeah so you know keep those
moderator boats coming in I think it's
awesome there are certainly titles we
never would have seen and otherwise and
we want to make sure you know that one
of the one of the great things about the
show is that we can actually you know
show off some really really cool games
you might not have otherwise sound I'm
doing and these games do and you know
when when a games really good quality
this is one of the channels that
that the play team uses to find features
tiles so even just last week right we
had the Shogun yeah absolutely so we you
know it can actually happen and this is
a great channel for that I don't think
they actually watch the show but we give
them the summary afterwards yeah so
which is good because other cuz you know
sometimes it's better not to know what
know how much drinking actually does go
on in the context of the show so uh they
read my expense reports they must guess
that's true uh so in any case thank you
once again for joining us and hope you
have a great i'll give a great rest of
your april twentieth two thousand twelve
happy 420 see you later